um cause of as inverse and close inverse
of cause I think now if you remember
let's just think back to a two hours ago
the first one we did was this okay do
you remember now which one was which I
think back to this inside pie okay which
is the definitive product so since sine
inverse had that restriction on it the
whole thing also has its restriction so
that's why you only get one small
section of white sorry that's again a y
equals x okay so when you flip it around
I don't know if any of you came up with
a wording for this right in the middle
it's still the same but as you as you go
outside that middle domain from minus PI
to 2 pi to what do you get you get this
kind of shape now how would you wear it
here's what I would work so if you
haven't written down you know an
explanation for what happens outside
this domain of - planet una planta -
here's the way I would say it I think
what you get is horizontally shifted
versions shifted oh now what graph does
it look like
well I see I'm doing louder and down and
up and down yeah it's kind of like the
absolute value of x I think that's the
closest comparison now I know a lot of
you when you look at it it kind of looks
like sine X but but pointy okay as you
will see when we look at mainly close
right now that comparison starts to
break down it's actually closer to this
kind of life right because that's what
the equation of this part is that's y
equals x that little branch section okay
all right now what happens when you take
the other ones close of cos inverse and
so let's do this whimpers okay
now let's try rather than just you know
bluntly putting in values appear let's
try to replace some of the logic and
what we saw over here and think about
this okay so for what values of X do you
think it's going to exist where's it
going to work yeah just like just like
this sine inverse of X right since there
was a restriction on that you're going
to get the same kind of thing happening
here but anything since this is minus 1
to 1 and this is minus 1 to 1 you're
going to get exactly the same
restriction okay so to cut a long story
short okay you're getting the same graph
okay so cos cos inverse and science sine
inverse they're actually equal to each
other within that domain okay
now things get a little more interesting
I'm gonna rub this off in sections
pretty boring when you think about cos
inverse of cos x okay so let me get rid
of
okay now come back over here right
remember that this was equal to X in
this domain here from - power - to pile
- okay
now that restriction is not an accident
it's not arbitrary that restriction
comes from distribution right that this
is limited between - Pam - and Pinal -
okay now think for a second well we need
cos inverse when we decided where we
were we were restrict cos inverse we
came up with a different restriction
didn't win what was its restriction zero
is unifier right okay
so therefore you ought to expect the
same kind of pattern to happen here
right so you're going to get y equals x
within this domain so I'm going from
here to here that's why I chose X okay
and that's not too high okay now what
would you expect to happen after that
now keep in mind remember signing close
right side and close they're the same
graph but they're shifted horizontally
okay
now I've also got this vertical shift
happening because I've chosen a
different restriction okay but you're
basically going to get the same shape
it's going to bounce just like
cyberverse of sine balanced okay now
here's why I was trying to make this
comparison before to the absolute value
of X rather than see it's like sine but
oh okay this graph here y equals cos
inverse of closets it looks nothing like
AWS right what does cause they play
looks like this
it doesn't really mine up does it okay
but you could cry the same or it's
upside down and it's shifted but the
yeah because you know it's it's high
here and low there but the comparison
really breaks down right so instead I'm
going to connect it to the absolute
value of X again right so this part here
is another horizontally shifted version
of the absolute value of x right so it's
been moved over that far okay now let
that have been 2 pi this has come down
to 3 PI if I drew that far you get the
idea